[Music]
this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we're going to
feature
an exclusive interview with the one and
only
richard dawkins richard dawkins has a
new book
called books do furnish a life which
we'll spend
a lot of time talking about because it
goes everywhere and that's where we want
to go
richard dawkins professionally is an
ethologist
an evolutionary biologist and author
popularizer of his field in science in
general in rational thinking
all around and so much of what he does
is what we celebrate here on star talk
so we've got him richard welcome back to
star talk this is not your first rodeo
with us
it's such a pleasure neil thank you very
much yeah i was looking at your
book oh my gosh richard that
dare i say dare i even suggest
that if anyone read only one book of
yours
it should be this because this to me
reads like a
cross-section of everything you have
cared about and expressed professionally
and in the public with regard to what
your life has been about
is that a fair characterization well
it's very interesting i never thought of
that before neil thank you
um it does span much of my career
ever since i started reviewing books i
suppose and writing forwards to books
so yes it's a good slice of my
increasingly alarmingly long career
alarmingly
and i you know so i i worried because
people who start
sort of collecting their life's works
it's almost like they're ready to die
and i don't want you dying anytime soon
so just that that's why i was worried
when uh oh
uh oh let me check this heart rate well
let me
let me reassure you i've got two books
two other books coming out
um uh one in november and one not quite
sure when but anyway
the one in november uh i'm looking
forward to very much
it's called flights of fancy and it's
about flight uh
and um so i i'm not checking out anytime
soon
okay stay alive at least until your last
book gets published
uh i'm also i noted uh as
do many prolific authors in the first
section of the book called front matter
there's a list of all of your previous
books
and i went down the list and forgive me
richard i haven't read
all 30 of them 15
no but i've read like three and a half
okay
and i got the list i've read the selfish
gene i've read the blind watchmaker
i've read the god delusion and i've read
parts of
other books and i can say that every
one of your books i've read each one of
the books of yours i've read
is a jewel it's a jewel of writing it's
a jewel of science communication
it's a jewel of intellect so i will
extrapolate and declare
that every one of these books is a jewel
and it forms a crown
of some kind some kind of bejeweled
crown
that is a gift to civilization of how
you think
and how you would welcome others to
think to make a better world
how kind what what can i say i mean
i'd love to think that okay so let's go
straight into some of these topics i
very much embraced your organization of
the book there's sections and each
section
sort of delves into a an
area of of
science as it relates and as it is
received
by the public and and i'm honored
actually to be mentioned in your first
section
um where you recount an interview that
we had
in my office at the hayden planetarium
we talked about science communication
and we were sort of
trading notes as how i remember it and
to see you know what succeeded what
didn't and
what i want for you if can you tell me
over your years what have you learned to
do
differently based on
either the trial and error of your
successes or failures or
did you find one recipe and you sort of
stuck with it all the way through
i'd be interested to know what you'd
what your answer to that question is
neil as well i
i don't have much of a recipe and if
anybody ever
invites me to give a talk on something
like science communication
i don't really know what to say i mean i
just do it
i suppose what one of the things that i
do is to
put myself in the position of the reader
i mean that's an obvious thing how could
anyone not do that and yet
many people don't actually um you have
to imagine yourself in the position of
the reader who would
or the listener who would wonder what's
he getting at there what's happening
there
i don't i don't get that point please
elaborate on that point
so i tend to imagine
an imaginary reader looking over my
shoulder
and it can be a particular person it
could be
a person that um oh
perhaps wrote me a letter that day and
so i've got him or her in my mind and so
i imagine
how would it be what would it be like
for her reading this what would be like
for him reading this
i don't know whether you do anything
like that i do that
yeah of course all the time but i add
another aspect to it
i think and again with varying success
most people don't read
so for me i always ask myself
is there something i can add to this
that will attract
someone who doesn't have walls of books
behind them you know in in their bedroom
or in their den
and so that involves some sensitivity to
just people in the street and so i'm
wondering
for you um how what is the difference to
you between
the written word and the spoken word or
the written word and the conversation
you're having someone who's just
curious in the street you can't just
tell them read my 400 page book
does it that doesn't work um and
actually you're reminding me neil of
of one of our first encounters when you
took me to task i think it might have
been in
san diego or maybe seattle or something
like that um
and you said that maybe you said
something like
it's got to be an act of seduction an
act of persuasion
um as opposed to here's my book take it
or leave it
and you've just as it were reiterated at
that point it's a very good point
um i certainly try to do that obviously
to try to do that when i'm talking face
to face with somebody i mean you
you read the body language you read the
facial language you you see is it going
in are they are they getting it are they
shaking their head with doubt
um are they looking in the sort of
blanking comprehension
um so that's easy when you're face to
face with somebody
when you're faced with a large audience
which is a mixed audience
you don't quite know you can't tell how
people are reacting
and of course with the book it's even
worse because you can't even see
their eyes as their reading um
i suppose i try to take account of all
those things when i'm writing
um but it's not easy well let me tell
you let me remind you what i
precisely what i took you to task about
and just to to sharpen that memory was
it was a conference one one of the early
conferences that landed on youtube
and so it got a lot of awareness uh
received a lot of attention at the time
today it might get lost in sort of the
noise of what's been posted
but 2006 and they finally got all the
talks together by 2007
so it was early clickable internet
content
um and it had a mixture of scientists
and
a couple of theologians if i remember
correctly skeptics and it was just
it's called beyond belief you know what
where do we go
if belief is not going to be the
centerpiece here
all i told you at the table which was
the
very first day i had met you by the way
and i was very nervous
because you're one of you're one of my
heroes of
i was nervous too of science and
communication
and what i what i i had seen you give a
talk
at this very same conference damn this
guy is
sharp and the wit is just barbed
and it's like and he knows he's right
and
he knows who he's talking to is wrong
and it was just
it was so precise and so there was no
room to have a person
just say can you let me just
i don't know recover for a moment
and so i worried that your messaging
was missing people because of how
articulately
barbed it was that it might have
actually turned people off
and then i i said perhaps you can
go at this with a
with a more of a subtle art of
persuasion
rather than just saying i'm i'm
paraphrasing here you're all idiots read
my book you'll be fine for
it see so that was that's what i came at
you for it
and it's all coming back to me very
vividly now
and i was i was very um i was moved by
it actually
what i said at the time i think was i
gratefully accept the rebuke
and and i did yes you did
you were very gracious about it and by
the way no one back then knew
me from adam but they all knew you and
when i said this
it was basically an attack and there was
this
eerie silence in the room
after i had spoken and and when you said
i gratefully
accept your rebuke it was like oh
it got a great laugh not least from you
i mean i i i recall i can actually hear
it again
your wonderful laugh as i said that um
and i hope i've learned from that i i
don't know whether i have
i wonder whether you agree with me that
sometimes
if you make a great effort to be clear
as we both do it can come across as
a bit aggressive sometimes people like
to hear
a bit of flanneling around a bit of a
bit of woolly talk
and if you if you make a real effort to
talk clearly
they think it's somehow
two in your face yeah so that's
there is what you think it is and
there's how it's received right and as
you can be an educator who
faces the chalkboard and puts the notes
on the board and not
really paying attention or you can try
to meet the people
not just halfway but maybe 90 percent of
the way
to their own space of thinking and
yeah by the way this i will talk more
about this a little later but
my primary the primary value of social
media to me
apart from what it is to wade through
the cesspool
that it is is i get to see
how people are thinking based on what
words i chose
what phrase i composed what idea i put
on the page
and i can say oh you're all wrong or you
misinterpreted me no
this is a real this is a real experiment
in progress if they misinterpreted you
if they didn't understand the word how
you used it if
if that happened that actually happened
it is
real so so i've used social media as my
source of awareness
of how people think what they think and
what i might want to do if i want to be
more effective
that's interesting i mean i i find your
your tweets which i look at from time to
time
are very interesting because you tend to
be
i think you think of yourself as an
educator which you are and
and you tend to um give little snippets
of
in interesting fascinating science in a
witty kind of way
and uh so your arrest it seems to me
that what you're doing is arousing
people's excitement for science
by what you tweet and
i wouldn't i hadn't realized that you
were actually looking out for how people
respond to that that's interesting
yeah that's my that's my so in a way
it think of it as a sort of a
neurosynaptic
snapshot of how people are thinking
about what you're saying so that next
time you're in front of a large audience
in an auditorium let's say you now have
a
portfolio of the at least a statistical
portfolio
of how people are thinking and what
they're thinking and why and what
they're
um and how they're reacting more
importantly so that's
that's kind of how i how i think about
it
[Music]